oggi una giornata super speciale perché
stiamo andando a prendere non vi spoiler
o troppo ma vi faccio vedere degli indie
anche primo indizio una copertina
rosa quindi forse si capisce ciò che è
una femminuccia secondo inizio
un topino giochino che ne avrete già
capito e poi per servizio un
trasportino
e rosa anche questo tutto cosa che
sapete bene ormai che è una femminuccia
che stiamo
emozionatissimi e da tantissimi anni che
vogliamo adottare una gattina un gattino
e questo caso il ragazzino siamo troppo
emozionati non vedevo l'ora di farvelo
conoscere anche di raccontarvi la sua
storia perché ha una storia incredibile
e poi ovviamente scegliere un nome
pronti andiamo ed ecco berlino berlino è
ancora un po confuso non è sicuro di
quello che succederà gara è lì a questo
gioco non è perché è per la tua nuova
sorellina e vi arriverà fra poco berlina
6 contesa che arriva la tua sorellina
però farlo carmine un po confuso
vorrebbe forse distruggere il
trasportino vero
sembra
ragazzi stiamo in macchina acqua dentro
c'è la nuova arrivata
per me la faccio vedere
vediamo se riuscite a vederla se non la
vedrete meglio poi a causa hai visto
paronuzzi all alta la dietro c'è berlino
non so se lo vedete
dietro ancora il pomodoro
[Musica]
vediamo se riuscite a vederla eccola lì
lì molto tranquilla non ha paura mi devi
come tranquilla anzi anche già preso il
giochino ora si sta un po pulendo il
pelo
cari
ragazzi
qui dentro
ora la faccio uscire così la conoscerete
bene si prenda piccolina
improta insieme
eccola qua
[Musica]
guardate quanti piccoli
ea due mesi
proprio piccolo piccola sta andando a
controllare il cuscino gatto
odorando tutto perché qua e dove dorme
berlino quindi sta controllando tutto
tutto
ciao
poi libico la
chicca ri
[Musica]
scriveteci nei commenti dei consigli per
i nomi bordo
no
mi chiamo doveva mettiamo la terra e
ridiamo
viene aperto di voi vuole già conoscervi
guarda un po il giochino
adora giocare
e super
giocherellona ma anche office volta
creta
quest'app è come gioca con la pallina
le ditte
[Risate]
e super vivace e piena di energia vuole
sempre giocare
e io prenderò
[Musica]
carina vuole sempre giocare
piene di super carina
trovava potrò da questo giochino e gli
piace tantissimo questa topino con le
piume anche questo le piace guarda
questo perché il piatto più cui giochi e
adesso
si diverte tantissimo
è vicina con le stesse in questi capelli
ragazzina con le station
eccola qui
ciao
[Musica]
e ancora più piccola
è uno scritto letto
piccolino b con il
micio
e disse sintesi sta bene si sta bene
adesso agli occhi
verde
[Musica]
da provando ad attaccare indotto grande
kit predatrice
è piccola piccola ma pensa di essere
[Musica]
gli occhi
topino
in modalità
esplorazione
[Risate]
buona storia
dove scoprire
e ora vi raccontiamo la sua storia
perché ha una storia molto particolare
piccolina è stata fortissima
anche se piccola piccola piccola ha un
cuore di leone coraggiosissima infatti
questa gattina è sopravvissuta ad una
volta la mamma purtroppo non ce l'ha
fatta e quindi le era molto molto
piccola ed è cresciuto senza la mamma
mio padre si è occupato di lei le ha
dato il latte specifico per gattini con
un apposito biberon per gattini piccoli
appunto e lei è riuscito a sopravvivere
l'unica cosa che ha un problemino alla
zampe sta dietro avete visto quando
corre ogni tanto cade quindi a questo
problemino la zampetta ma l'abbiamo già
portata dal veterinario e la stiamo
curando piano piano dovrebbe riprendersi
speriamo che sarà per me io con questa
vico per coccolosa tra l'altro noi ci
siamo innamorati di presepi
[Musica]
e anche una piccola peste come ho già
detto anita è molto forte e quando
l'abbiamo portata dal veterinario sia
attaccata al suo guanto e non lo volevo
lasciarlo andare
via forse in quanto non voleva lasciarlo
andare in quanto del veterinario noi di
teo poliziano sezionati tantissimo e
siamo
felicissimi
consigliateci qualche nome per questa
piccolina nei commenti noi abbiamo
qualche nome in mente ma vogliamo anche
i vostri compare poi potrai scegliere
lei da sola come ha fatto un berlino li
ricordate che mi piace se volete vedere
altri video collegati a mi raccomando
vogliatevi piazza e qua sotto seguitemi
su instagram se volesse vedere dei video
e delle porte della gattina
delle stories delle foto della gattina
prese ci saranno altri video conquista
gattino quindi attivate la campanella
stimata di notifiche con la campanella
per sé il perdermi ii e ora vi lasciamo
4 sterline per cui cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite
[Applauso]